only order no chaos
it sounds boring i'm sure it does to you
you know you called me a scared little
boy
i called you a lot of things you did
you're wrong you see i know something
children don't
what's that but no one bad is ever truly
bad
and no one good is ever truly good happy
loki day
everyone carlos here aside from it being
a big week for bonnie tyler's holding
out for a hero
it's also a big week for a very popular
loki theory big spoilers ahead for loki
episode two this
is et canada's nerd
episode 2 gives us a lot of useful info
about the sacred timeline and the tva
things that will be important for us to
know as the series goes on we learned
that there's a point
after a nexus event occurs that the tva
can't correct it
what happens when a nexus event branches
past redline
very bad things come on loki what is it
it's when the tva can no longer reset a
nexus event
okay boring right and that would lead to
the destruction of the timeline
and the collapse of reality as we know
it now it seems as though
only judge renslayer has ever met the
timekeepers which is
more than a little suspicious and how
are the all
time keepers how do you think
i don't know because i've never met him
thankfully although i shouldn't say that
that one looks like he's got the
timekeepers i'm monitoring every aspect
of this case
i've never seen them so involved and
that the greatest invention of all time
is the jet ski in the early 1990s for a
brief
shining moment there was a beautiful
union
of form and function which we call the
jet ski
and a reasonable man cannot differ
you have been on one no not sure if that
scene is foreshadowing mobius eventually
saving the day on a jet ski or
jet ski sales just skyrocketing in 2021
you know probably both in joining up
with the tva our loki learns that
they've pruned plenty of loki variants
from various timelines
gotta watch out for those pesky tour de
france loki's but the one they're on the
hunt for
is the most dangerous variant yet the
end of this episode reveals that that
loki the one who's jumping from timeline
to timeline
killing tva agents is a woman this
obviously confirms the lady loki
theories that sprung from those leaked
set photos last year
but what we didn't see then was a small
detail that could speak volumes about
the direction of this entire series
the broken crown up until now a lot of
attention has gone to
this version of lady loki from the
comics this is loki in the body that was
meant for sif when thor is sort of
waking up his fellow asgardians after
ragnarok that's
thor vol 3 by j michael strzezinski by
the way great read
anyway the loki we meet in rox cart in
2050 has a crown with one broken horn
significant because that's clearly
influenced
by this lady loki in the comic series
loki agents of asgard
that series sees loki coming to terms
with the evil they've done facing their
villainous destiny and taking steps to
alter it
choosing to be the loki they determined
to be instead of the one they're always
told they are
i don't want anybody out there to forget
what you are oh your only hope for
capturing a murderer no
a cosmic mistake but loki is an evil
lying scourge that is the part he plays
on the sacred timeline
why is it the people you can't trust are
always saying
trust me see what i mean now listen to
what tom hiddleston told me about what
this loki series is about
it asks questions of of all of us i
think about
our relationship to time our
relationship to the past our
relationship to the future
you know perhaps we do we have any
agency over the
choices we make or are those choices
somehow
have they been made for us are we active
in those things are we passive you know
it's really clear
and how we kind of to tell the story of
ourselves
to ourselves in order to construct a
a identity and how how robust is that
identity like you could
kind of um deconstruct it and maybe it
would all fall apart
i don't know these are good good
questions you made me think about it
so i know that i threw that in there
because tom hiddleston's a cool guy and
i'm pretty sure everyone just
loves hearing him talk so you're welcome
now even though loki claims to have a
plan where he's gone undercover to
overthrow the timekeepers
it felt to me more like grandstanding
than a grand scheme
i think we're in for some personal
growth here adding to that perhaps our
loki variant isn't the only one who's on
the course of self-realization
i think this new female variant isn't
just bombing the sacred timeline for
chaos's sake
maybe it's deeply personal like she's
rewriting her own story or trying to
restore a timeline
that the tva unjustly pruned because
they believed themselves to be the
ultimate authority
on any and all events ever always
a powerful group erasing history because
it doesn't suit their narrative
[Music]
social commentary and i'm here for it
this isn't about you
[Music]
right what did you think of loki episode
2 and where do you think we go from here
have you read loki agents of asgard
because i think you should it's pretty
dope also
will you be riding a jet ski this summer
let's talk about it in the comments
below i'm looking forward to reading
your theories
now next week we'll be doing a loki
mid-season nerd alert round table with
some special guests
getting their thoughts in the series so
far so make sure you come back for that
that's it for now see you next time
you